has been a murderer at lowry's the prime
rib and it's up to us to solve it this
thursday night at the murder mystery
dinner let's welcome to the show the
mystery performers we got jay laurie
judy and mickey all here welcome guys
it's great to have you here great to be
here now this is part of the big 25th
anniversary celebration that is huge
what's taking place on thursday we're
doing an interactive live stream well
live mystery not live streaming but we
do those uh right at the dinner so it's
like two courses of mystery and intrigue
and three-course meal of lowry's the
prime rib which is amazing so explain
everyone's not familiar murder murder
mystery this is an actual play that's
taking place why we're eating dinner
absolutely it is it's like a live game
of clue so you come in we start mingling
with you we bring you into our story
which is called lethal libations this
time and it's about a wine tasting we
are pretending to be the lowry's uh
distributor for the past 25 years now
there will be a wine tasting an actual
wine tasting
there is an option to do that yes
are there any other surprises happening
on thursday i mean this is a big
celebration 25th anniversary any other
surprises you can you can peel back the
curtain on all i can say is a lot of a
lot of surprises are going to become
uncorked oh i like that now before we
get a performance real quick what's the
menu like on thursday because lowry's
the food is there it's just incredible
it's the eight ounce prime rib or you
can have salmon and they also have a
vegetarian option as well you get the
spinning salad the signature spinning
salad and then of course you have the
wonderful chocolate dessert so good now
you guys are going to perform for us are
you going to murder are you going to
dance what are we going to do we have a
little something in store for you this
is claire valentine which is judy
lombino and lori caceres is priscilla
gillespie and grant taylor is mickey
rourke and
right now what's happening is claire is
looking for her boyfriend irwin okay and
scene
but anybody's saying priscilla
yes yes dear what is it do something
about that insipid woman i mean her
voice is like man's down a chalkboard
she's giving me a sick headache
my love you know your wish is my demand
i just have one quick question
which woman i mean there's a lot of them
claire claire you idiot claire well okay
calm down let's do our breathing
exercises ooh how about the prime
numbers okay ready
one
three
five
seven working just just tell me
something good something good oh you
know that transaction you wanted me to
do
well i didn't transfer one
not even two but three hundred thousands
that is wonderful grant now my brother's
days are numbered excuse me i have
something very exciting to tell you as
of this morning irwin and i are
engaged look priscilla we're gonna be
sisters i've always wanted an older
sister
let me see that
oh that is fake it's a piece of glass
and you're wearing it on the wrong hand
you idiot little they wear it in europe
you're just jealous cause a real man is
in love with me
excuse me i see a drink with my name on
it
and scene and singing oh baby crazy
old-timey television that was fantastic
real quick how can people get tickets
jake go to uh a touch of mystery.com or
you can call us at 702-497-7936